turning to my right over here good to
see the ACM award-winning artists here
gonna be singing the national anthem at
Bellator this weekend in Los Angeles
something's going on as his most recent
album released in March of last year
he's gonna be in the film I can only
imagine coming up in March of this year
good to see you Trace Adkins hello rich
good to see you
so you you what you have the deepest
voice I think of all time man that's a
great set of pipes brother I don't think
of all time when was the first time you
realized you could carry a tune yeah you
know I started singing a little bit and
George when I was a kid but I was too
shy to ever really do it I didn't start
singing in front of people chose 17 okay
and so did you because we were talking
before your do you seem like you could
have played football do you ever try
playing audience I love playing football
where'd you play in Louisiana yeah okay
yeah I went and played a year at
Louisiana Tech that's the alma mater of
Terry Brown that's right right right oh
you can't they don't let you forget it
either you walk in the Fieldhouse and
there's like a 20-foot mural of him at
the end of the Terry's everywhere he's
everywhere okay but yeah man I love
football what you play defensive and the
offensive end that's you pal good call
right there that's recess and how big
you are is like d4c you could come you
rush the quarterback yes if you try to
do well I tried to okay but you know I
also played offensive tackle when I was
in high school so I got down there and I
which starts with practices not work out
with the defensive ends and then they
put me at D add offensive tackle on the
Scout squad and I had to block a
two-time all-american every day and huh
he basically ended my career I didn't
have the mounted my knees wouldn't my
right knee wouldn't stay together so
when you're grown up who was your guy
who was the guy that you said I'd love
to be him or I'd love to play against
him if I should get to a certain level
who was your guy yeah play against
somebody I don't really know I grew up
in the time in Louisiana
you know it was Archie Manning you know
and one of the greatest people I've ever
meet Archie Manning I love that man
I think he's the greatest quarterback
that ever played that didn't ever get to
play on a good team you know who bless
his heart he just had so much talent he
just never got to play yeah those Saints
teams were just never it was tough
rolling up a Saints fan back then and
now it's now it's so Saints are still
your team right now see them do well
sure so you were on the wrong end on
Sunday yeah I just think the world drew
brees I think he's he's just an
incredible talent
mm-hmm yeah you know good god - that is
what happened to the Saints fans on
Sunday it sounds like a country song
that's just waiting to be written really
doesn't it sound like to you you're on
the wrong end you're about to win you're
about to go to the NFC Championship game
and that sort of thing happened I don't
know
look that's your area of the business I
don't know I don't want it no you don't
know it still I guess it's still that's
a still a sore spot I don't want to go
there yeah it's like yeah you get your
heart broken you don't write that song
the next day so if you met watching wait
have you have you have not met aren't
you no kidding no how about the rest of
the oh man hey I met Peyton okay but no
I haven't I haven't had the opportunity
okay Trace Adkins here on this edition
of the Rich Eisen show okay so you're
singing the national anthem coming up
this weekend yeah fella - are you an MMA
guy and all are you yeah yeah I mean I
don't keep up with with it in a whole
lot but any you know any guy will just
middle names rampage you know I'll go
watch that it was my middle names
rampage so is there you go trace rampage
Atkins yeah okay how many people know
that okay no no are we breaking news
breaking news fantastic alert the media
Chris will you please I'll tweet that
out right now man and then you're so are
you an SEC guy obviously or LSU would we
say that yeah LSU fan yeah I'm an SEC
yeah sure okay I live in Tennessee
you know that was an interesting job
search that they just recently had here
that was weird
okay so you've taught my daughter act my
one of my daughters actually goes to you
too so okay all right so we sent you
this song that we kind of created pissed
off of Nick Saban and he accepted the
podium this is one was this November
December Chris is right around there yes
yeah yeah early nove ceps to the podium
and he starts talking about how somebody
you strolled past coming to the podium
they just had torn up jeans ripped up
jeans holes in them and I heard it and I
said you know what if we set that to
music it sounds like a country music
song here it is
[Music]
I just wanted to know how we got here
not to offend anybody out there but I
just walked by some jeans wore out jeans
holes in them all cut up I just remember
when I was a kid in West Virginia I just
came to go to school cut my jeans were
wore out only because we didn't have any
better now they bond that way I just
wanted to know how we got here
[Music]
I just wanted to know how we got here
there you go we figured you know what
since you are an award winner you are as
good as they come man you are tres don't
worry you're so humble let me talk about
that wait so we figured we wrote the
lyrics out we wrote his soliloquy out
for you right do we have that yeah the
lyrics we got right there and but okay
we can set it up however you wish you
got your own way of doing it here we go
Trace Adkins everyone on the Richardson
show doing Nick Saban's how do we get it
I guess I just want to know how we got
here not to offend anybody out there but
I just walked by some jeans wore out
jeans with holes and I'm all cut up I
just remember when I was a kid in West
Virginia I was ashamed go to school
coach my jeans wore out only because we
didn't have any better
how they buy on that way and I just
wanna know
how did we get here tell me how did we
get here
[Music]
don't understand these kids these days
guess I never will somebody please
please tell me
how did we get here
people how did we get here is that I
somebody just my manager just a few
minutes ago showed me the new laminate
that we have for our tour this year
leader shine we you know what we're
gonna call this tour this year so I hope
there's no copyright infringement my
tour this year is gonna be the how did
we get here to it because it's so funny
you know cuz I asked that question all
the time you know when you when you do
something that you just feel like you
really got lucky and and something that
you're passionate about something that
you love to do turns into your career
and you get to make a living doing that
and sometimes you just have to step back
and go how do we get how did this happen
how do we get here you know I feel the
same way about my career I always think
my career is kind of like tore up jeans
holes in them well it's fantastic will
you really put that out allowing it
that's great enough but you've got to
send us one we've got it we go to here
in studio as a profile that's why
honestly when I first heard that press
conference I thought to myself that
sounds like a country music lyric to me
maybe we should just get all mix a band
just create the whole damn whole album I
just love it he just came out and just
said you know what he just disarmed
everybody I'm just gonna talk about what
I was talking about you know I just
noticed something outside and I gotta
talk about this he's like freaking Saban
that's great the Peppermill concert hall
in West Wenda Wendover Nevada on
February the 9th the Grand Old Opry in
Nashville Tennessee Bach Center in Tulsa
United supermarkets arena in Lubbock
those are the fort upcoming tour dates
and your new single what's your new
single what do you have for me on that
still a soldier yeah that's a new one
that we got out okay what's that about
well it's about you know it's it's it's
a tip of the hat to all those
veterans organizations that I've worked
with over the years and it has been the
most rewarding thing I think that I've
had an opportunity to do is associate
with those men and women that have
served and I've always come out better
for it but from my spending time with
them you know and so and and pretty much
to a man they all feel that way there's
there they're still soldiers at their
core and you know I don't care if they
live to be a hundred and twenty years
old there's still soldiers and that's
that's what this song is just a tip of
the hat to those men and women good for
you man because people aren't buying
albums listening to music if they don't
have the freedom to sit back and enjoy
that sort of go seriously and it's
something we take for granted all too
often in this country and then the film
I can only imagine about the most played
contemporary Christian song of all time
so it is I guess so yeah I just hired me
to play the the manager of the band
right okay so great and I met the guy
that's the first time I've ever met
somebody that I was portraying in a
movie and it was like looking at my
long-lost brother we're about the same
height about the same size and goatee
the whole thing it was weird no kidding
yeah well that's going to be in theaters
on March 16th enjoy the weekend at
Bellator come back anytime trace adkins
thanks very much for for that rendition
oh I'm sure it made fun of no I'm sure
Awards Oh in the offing I just open
didn't make saving mad then it'll just
wonder how he got here Trace Adkins
check him out on Twitter @ Trace Adkins
and again his most recent album
something going on and still a soldier
his most recent single good to see you
sir you bet 844 204 rich will take your
calls as we finish up our Thursday show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience